sabrina tu n'aurais donc je suis j'ai 49
ans donc je suis directrice d'école et
je suis arrivé en politique de en 2020
donc avec l'équipe de michel fontaine je
suis adjointe à la mairie de
saint-pierre donc je m'occupe des
affaires scolaires de la commune et puis
donc nouvellement conseillère
départementale sur cette mandature avec
sur le président cyrille melchior et
j'ai demandé à la délégation de la vie
éducative du collège et je suis aussi en
charge de la politique inclusive des
personnes en situation de handicap
je suis élu sur le canton 22 avec mon
binôme maire de petite-île serge hoareau
donc je suis originaire de saint pierre
et puis je connais bien le canton
puisque j'ai travaillé cinq ans aussi en
tant que directrice d'école sur le
quartier de manapany débat à petit il
donc c'est un canton qui s'étend jusque
jusqu'à la partie la partie ouest de
saint joseph quand on man 2 c'est un
canton qui allie la modernité à la
ruralité puisque c'est ça mon verre
qu'on fait la fraise c'est un petit il
qu'on fait la hisse à la plaine des
grègues ont fait safran donc les
activités agricoles sont importantes en
dansant sur ce territoire nous devons
donc soutenir les agriculteurs dans
leurs activités quotidiennes
alors en parallèle bien sûr continuer ce
qui a été fait par nos prédécesseurs en
particulier dans l'organisation des
déplacements de la population
notamment dans la sécurité des routes et
aussi dans le domaine de la transition
écologique au niveau départemental le
domaine de l'éducation est essentielle
et nous allons donner les moyens
nécessaires au collège pour qu'il puisse
accompagner les collégiens dans l'eure
dans leur projet éducatif et dans le
domaine de la politique inclusive
accompagner chaque personne en situation
de handicap dans la construction de leur
projet de vie
est bien en continuant en renforçant les
infrastructures et les équipements de
proximité aller vers la population
réunionnaise et nous élus être de plus
en plus proche de cette population parce
que être visible dans tout ce que l'on
fait et est plus de communication autour
de tous les dispositifs existants
qu'importe le formidable outil qu'est le
département